nice la parole et à monsieur thierry
solère merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
l'agression s'est produite dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche à lyon il est deux
heures du matin un jeune homme de 26 ans
demande à un taxi de le conduire chez
lui mais le chauffeur affirme être en
grève et refusent de le prendre en
charge le svg décide d'appeler un hubert
pop
il est directement pris à partie par
plusieurs chauffeurs de taxi qu'ils
agressent violemment le jeune homme
reçoit plusieurs coups de poing au
visage 21 jours d'itt et et la tension
monsieur le premier ministre entre les
chauffeurs de taxi et les conducteurs de
vtc est à son comble plusieurs
conducteurs de vtc ont et ont porté
plainte ces derniers jours après avoir
été agressé par des taxis à strasbourg
nice ou lille
rien que la semaine dernière une
centaine de faits de violence grave
aurait d'après la presse eut lieu en
france sur des chauffeurs ou des clients
devaient essayer par des chauffeurs
thaksin
monsieur le premier ministre la loi du
1er octobre 2014 dit thévenoud
ambitionnait de créer un équilibre un
écrit libre entre des règles de
développement pour les vtc et des
efforts nécessaires de modernisation
pour les taxis ainsi qu'un encadrement
de cette profession pour une concurrence
loyale
votre stratégie est d'abord un échec
politique puisqu'elle débouchent sur des
violences qui sont inacceptables dans
les rues de france et qu'à ce jour
aucune juridiction l'a estimé que le
service du dr pop et est illégal
votre stratégie d'un échec économique la
commission thévenoud avait estimé à 70
milles la création d'emplois dans ce
secteur résultat vos services ans
déclare au bout de six mois très
exactement 215 alors que parallèlement
environ 1500 demandes de dossiers sont
enregistrées par semaine chez les
compagnies de l'été c'est votre
stratégie est ensuite un échec
écologique
comment comprendre que vous interdisez
avait essayé de rouler en véhicule
électrique que vous les y obliger à
retourner à leur garage entre deux
courses elle est enfin un échec social
on parle monsieur le premier ministre
d'un million et demi d'utilisateurs par
mois en france et beaucoup parmi les
chauffeurs sont des jeunes souvent issus
de quartiers difficiles qui auparavant
étaient éloignés de l'emploi monsieur le
premier ministre
qu'allez vous faire pour mettre enfin un
terme à ces violences mais pour régler
le moulin d'elena par l'état monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur
oui monsieur le député thierry solère
votre question repose sur une confusion
la loi du mois d'octobre à laquelle vous
faites référence déposés par un
parlementaire est une loi qui
définissait les conditions qui
définissait les conditions d'exercice de
la profession de taxi et de la
profession de vtc et ceux qui sont en
cause aujourd'hui ce ne sont pas les vtc
qui a acquis des charges sociales et qui
procède au paiement aussi de leurs
charges fiscales ce qui est en cause
c'est une activité conduite par une
société la société hubert pop qui met
des chauffeurs parfois sans permis dans
des véhicules alors que ces chauffeurs
et sept sociétés n'acquittent aucune
charge sociale et fiscale et je
comprends donc de votre question que
vous considérez que face aux vtc face
aux chauffeurs de taxi il faudrait dans
la dérégulation la plus pure accepter
que les activités soient soumis à une
concurrence déloyale qui n'a qu' aucune
charge sociale conduit ses activités
dans l'illégalité
alors qu'il y a des taxis et des vtc qui
depuis cette fois acquise des acquis des
charges sociales acquittent des charges
fiscales et par conséquent dans une
concurrence loyale accomplissent des
activités bien ce n'est pas la doctrine
du gouvernement parce que le
gouvernement considère que hubert pop
est en situation d'illégalité absolue et
que le droit doit passer et que les
règles de la concurrence doivent être
respectés c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous prenons un certain nombre de
dispositions pour que ces troubles à
l'ordre publique résultant de la
conduite d'une activité manifestement
illégal par une société qui enfreint le
droit que ces troubles à l'ordre public
cesse et comment nous allons le faire
nous allons faire en multipliant les
réunions de codaf pour qu' il y ait des
poursuites à l'égard de ceux qui
n'acquittent aucune charge sociale et
aucune charge fiscale nous allons le
faire par une circulaire adressée au
procureur par la garde des sceaux
demandant au procureur de déclencher
systématiquement l'action publique
nous allons le faire en saisissant le
csa de manière à ce que le csa condamne
des publicités mensongères
visiblement elle aussi en infraction
avec le droit pour que le droit parce je
suis même allé plus loin